Narrator: These are the Sharks.
They have achieved
incredible success
as entrepreneurs and investors
in multiple sectors.
They all came
from humble beginnings
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
And tonight,
Silicon Valley veteran
and self‐made
billionaire investor Chris Sacca
returns to the Tank.
We think we can do
$1.5 million.
What are you
doing here?
Narrator: This is the art
of doing business.
I feel like
I've seen it before.
Sacca: Have you guys
already raised money?
$1.2 million.
That's not good news.
That's not good news at all.
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
Oh, God!
[ Chuckles ]
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a business seeking
to add affordable
and sustainable protein
to a favorite snack.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Rose Wang.
I'm from San Francisco,
California,
here seeking $100,000
for 7% of my company, called...
Oh, God!
...Chirps,
the first‐ever cricket chip.
My God!
Hi! My name
is Laura D'Asaro,
and I'm the other founder
of Chirps.
Sharks, it's time to eat
what bugs you with Chirps.
Now, you've seen
a cricket product before,
and you know that crickets
are one of the healthiest,
most sustainable
protein sources out there.
But you also know
what the challenge is ‐‐
How do we get people
to eat bugs?
To get people excited
about eating bugs,
we put crickets in America's
favorite snack food ‐‐ chips.
Chirps are what we call
our gateway bug,
because chips are something
people already love to eat.
Chirps tastes like
a good corn chip,
but in one serving,
you get as much protein
as an egg white and 30% less fat
than regular potato chips.
They're non‐GMO,
gluten‐free, and all‐natural.
And the best part ‐‐
There's one cricket per chip.
And Chirps are just
the beginning.
If we can get people excited
about eating bugs,
we can put bugs
in all sorts of foods!
So, who wants to chip in
the future and try some Chirps?
Both: Bug Appétit!
[ Laughter ]
Okay, so we're
gonna try these.
Yeah, absolutely.
Bring them on.
There's one cricket
per chip.
Per chip.
Yeah.
Cuban:
Why just one in ‐‐
There's not that much protein
in one cricket.
There ‐‐ So, our chips have
4 grams of protein per serving.
Right now, we want
to have more cricket flour,
but for a lot of our consumers,
they think one cricket
is enough.
How many crickets
per bag?
So, in the small ones,
there's about 70.
One cricket per chip.
Kind of smells a little funky
when you open it.
Well, let me
ask you something.
Okay.
Looking on the ingredients,
number 1 is corn.
Right.
Then you have beans.
Then cricket flour.
Right.
So what is the point
of using the crickets?
What we wanted to do
is create a chip
that's one of
the highest‐protein chips
on the market
and also have
other healthy ingredients
that complement
the cricket flour
to introduce it
to consumers.
You taste them,
people would buy them.
The flavor's great ‐‐
particularly, your barbecue,
I thought, was really tasty,
nice and crisp.
I think
they're delicious.
Am I tasting the flavor
I'm picking up?
Is that from the cricket,
or is that from other flavoring?
So, the cricket has a ‐‐
It's like kind of an umami.
It adds a depth
to the flavor.
Mm‐hmm.
It's slightly nutty,
but you might be getting
some of the beans,
as well,
that are in the chips.
I see.
So, tell the story.
What got you into this?
So, Rose and I were
college roommates at Harvard,
and I studied abroad
in Tanzania
and ended up meeting this woman
selling fried caterpillars.
I bought one, and my first
thought when I bit down was,
"This tastes
like lobster."
And so I got back and started
researching eating insects
and found out they're
so sustainable, so healthy.
And I was like,
"Why aren't people eating this?"
So I sent Rose an article
about eating insects.
[ Chuckles ]
And I had just
come back from China,
where I had
a fried scorpion
and had the same reaction
she did, which ‐‐
"Oh, this tastes
like shrimp."
We're like, "Well, let's try to
get other people to eat bugs."
Outside the United States,
this is really normal.
About 80% of countries
eat insects,
and it's often
a delicacy.
Africa ‐‐ big.
Yeah. So, I was
an African‐studies major,
and, like, when
the termites came out,
it was like,
"Celebration time!"
This isn't just about
eating bugs, right?
Yeah.
Right.
Right, there's got to be
a social component there.
There's got to be
a bigger mission.
What is it?
Yeah, for us,
insects are one of the most
sustainable protein sources
out there.
So, for example, it takes
2,000 gallons of water
to make a pound of beef
but only one gallon of water
to make a pound of crickets.
Crickets are, by far,
one of the healthiest,
most sustainable
protein sources.
What does one bag cost?
Yeah, so, our small snack size
is $1.99, and our ‐‐
That's what
we have here?
Yes.
Yeah, those guys.
And then the big ones here
are $3.99.
And what does it cost you
for a small?
A small is 48 cents now.
We could get it down
to 40 cents.
For the whole bag?
That's not bad.
Yeah.
So, we actually just signed on
with the two largest
natural‐food distributors
in the U. S.
We are in
73 airport stores,
as well as 20
natural‐food stores currently.
And what ‐‐
what will you sell this year?
So, this year, we're gonna end
the year about $200,000.
Okay, and next year,
what do you think you can do?
We think we can do
$1.5 million.
Whoa!
That's a big jump.
Why would that be?
Based on what?
One of our biggest clients that
are coming to us are museums,
zoos, aquariums,
theme parks.
We're in the biggest theme park
in the Southeast,
and so from even
just one of these parks,
we can turn about
100 bags per SKU per week.
So that's
a much bigger velocity
than you would get
at a natural‐food store.
The snack business is a
multi‐billion‐dollar franchise.
Yes.
You know, Miss Happy over there,
you're smiling so much.
[ Laughter ]
When you get into
a large retailer that says,
"You want 2 linear feet
in my snack department?"
They're gonna say,
"Give me a million bucks,"
and you won't be
smiling so much,
because you're gonna
have to buy your share.
I really am concerned, and I ‐‐
You know, I say this on deals
where you're trying
to steal share
from a very old,
established market.
They are gonna crush you
like the cockroaches you are.
Yes.
We knew you were gonna
call us a cockroach.
We were waiting for that.
[ Laughs ]
We are so excited
this happened.
How are you gonna
get a share?
I think the first thing
to point out
is that we're not a
"Me, too" product on shelves.
There's no other
cricket chip out there,
and that's
great marketing.
That's something that will draw
customers into stores.
We get a lot of free press.
Do you raise any money?
Yeah, so, we have
bootstrapped this
by winning
pitch competitions.
We've won over $200,000
at pitch competitions...
Good for you.
Wow.
... to build this.
But in terms of equity, no.
We own all of the company.
Greiner:
What's your next move?
What do you really see
you doing with bugs?
Yeah, so, we see Chirps as
what we call our gateway bug.
But really,
what we want to see
is a whey protein replacement
on the market,
and so cricket flour
could really be
that whey protein
replacement,
like shakes or juices
and things like that.
So, like, a protein mix ‐‐
a protein shake mix.
Right, exactly.
Yeah.
So, this is obviously an area
that's interesting to me.
Yeah.
And I agree
with your mission.
I agree with your vision.
Yeah.
Right?
Obviously,
I have Chapul.
Yeah.
But I also have Nuts n More.
I have Alyssa's Healthy Cookies.
All that are in this category.
All are high‐protein.
Yes.
Yeah.
Very high protein.
All look for
various protein sources.
Right.
So sustainable protein
is something
that I'm very interested in.
Right.
So I'll save you some time
in all this.
I want to make you
an offer.
Okay.
I'll give you the $100,000,
but I need 20%,
because you're gonna be working
with the companies I mentioned,
but it's got to be
worthwhile to me.
Greiner:
I'll tell you something ‐‐
I think he's a fantastic partner
and a great deal for you.
I'm out.
Okay. Thanks, Lori.
I was waiting
for a "but."
Cuban: Guys, I wasn't
setting this up.
I was gonna get
really excited.
Yeah, I wasn't setting this up
to just, "Okay, I'll wait here."
If you want
to counter, counter.
If you don't want
to do the deal,
say, "I just don't want
to do the deal."
Okay.
Would you do
$100,000 for 15%?
Done.
Whoo!
Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
Greiner: The Cricket King
and Queens.
Cuban: Thank you.
Oh, my God!
[ Laughs ]
Great job, guys.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Guys, the product
is really good.
Congratulations.
Let's get America
eating bugs!
Whoo!
[ Both laugh ]
Oh, my God!
[ Both laughing ]
Wow!
Oh, my gosh!
It feels amazing.
Like, when we first started,
everyone told us we were crazy.
"This is never
gonna work.
Nobody's gonna
believe in this."
And to have Mark Cuban, who is
a well‐seasoned entrepreneur,
who really gets this,
to believe in us,
I mean,
it's a dream come true.
♪♪
Corcoran: I was born and raised
in Edgewater, New Jersey,
with my nine siblings
in a two‐bedroom flat.
My dad was the hardest‐working
man alive.
He worked as a printing press
foreman during the day,
and he washed trucks at night
so he could support his kids.
My mother
was a full‐time housewife.
She was the best mom in town,
and she adored her children.
I always wanted to grow up
and be just like her.
I was a straight‐"D" student
my entire childhood.
I didn't learn until I was much
older that I had been dyslexic,
but in those days,
you got labeled "the dumb kid."
And in hindsight,
that was a gift,
'cause I had all day long
to daydream,
'cause I couldn't learn a thing.
I spent my entire life trying
to prove, once and for all,
that I am not stupid.
That's the truth.
That's what drives me.
I graduated from college
with a degree in education,
and I decided to become,
of all things, a teacher.
I hated it.
I had 22 jobs before I landed
the one that would make me rich.
I was working as a waitress
at a diner
and met a man
who became my boyfriend.
And he was the guy who said,
"With your personality, you'd be
great in real‐estate sales."
He offered to start
a real‐estate company.
He became my partner
and took 51% of the stock.
The company I started rented
apartments in New York City,
and so my job
was to run around town
opening doors for people
and chatting them up.
And I just loved
every minute of it.
Within two years,
I had 14 agents
and a half a million dollars
in sales.
Five years later,
my boyfriend came home
and announced
he was marrying my secretary.
I thought I would die.
On the day I divided
the business, my boyfriend said,
"You'll never succeed
without me."
When I started
the Corcoran Group,
people thought I was cute, but
they didn't take me seriously.
Inside, I was anything but cute.
I was dead‐serious
about becoming
the largest real‐estate broker
in New York City.
The Corcoran Group was
the innovator in the industry.
We were the first company
to sell real estate
on the Internet.
Barbara Corcoran.
Her business
is the crème de la crème.
Corcoran:
I was competing against giant
companies all owned by men.
It was the old‐boy network,
and I was not invited in.
A lot of people think
that being a woman
in business is a disadvantage,
but I saw it as a great asset.
I was different
than the old guys
that I was competing with.
The undisputed champion.
Corcoran:
By 2001, we had more sales
than any other competitor
in New York City,
and I realized my dream
of being the queen
of New York real estate
had just come true.
♪♪
When we were growing up here,
this was a rough neighborhood.
It was a factory town.
We were allowed to play
from that corner to that corner.
So this one block
was my world as a kid.
Everything happened here.
All 12 of us lived
on that ground floor there.
It felt so big then.
I still don't believe
we all fit there, honestly.
This street is chock‐full
of memories for me.
I have to pinch myself at times
to make sure it's all real,
because everything
I dreamt about,
from the time I was a little kid
till now, has come true for me.
When I think about growing up
in that two‐bedroom flat
with nine siblings,
and now I have a penthouse
[chuckles] on Fifth Avenue
in New York City,
where I can actually see
my hometown from my big terrace,
I think to myself,
"Isn't this a miracle?"
You never know what life brings.
Pretty remarkable.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a product
designed to optimize sound
while protecting your ears.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Jackson Mann,
from Minneapolis, Minnesota,
and my business is Vibes.
I'm here seeking $100,000
in exchange
for 20% of my company.
I want to change the way
people listen to live music.
I love going to concerts,
but that comes with a price.
I ended up rupturing my eardrum
at a concert due to loud sound.
Wanting to not do that again,
I did what most people do and
grabbed a pair of foam earplugs.
I put them in
and instantly realized
they are not designed for music.
They are designed
for snoring spouses,
mowing lawns,
construction sites ‐‐
things like this ‐‐
but not music.
This is what inspired me
to create Vibes ‐‐
high‐fidelity earplugs
designed for music.
They lower the decibel levels
of your environment,
while retaining
the sound quality,
so you hear the music
exactly as it's coming
through the speakers ‐‐
just at a lower decibel level.
Our goal is to make
a better concert experience,
save the world's hearing,
make earplugs cool,
and make a lot of money.
So, who wants to join me
on this journey with Vibes?
Can we get samples?
I would love
to hand them out to you.
All right,
thanks, Jackson.
Yep.
Here you are, Lori.
Greiner: Thank you.
Here you go,
Mr. Wonderful.
Thank you.
High‐fidelity earplug.
So, Vibes are reusable,
washable,
and virtually invisible.
Each pair comes with
three interchangeable tip sizes
and a hard‐size pocket
carrying case for easy storage.
They're
extremely comfortable.
But what's the difference
between this
and putting in
a rubber‐ish earplug?
So, a foam earplug
is blocking the sound,
and this is actually ‐‐
Vibes is actually filtering it.
It's lowering the decibels
equally from bass to treble.
Can I ‐‐ Can I run you
through a demo?
Mm‐hmm.
I'd love to.
Feel free to put them back in
like a pair of headphones.
Turn it to 11.
I don't know if these speakers
are gonna do it,
and I think we're gonna need
to take it up a notch.
So I would love to introduce,
from Minneapolis,
the McNasty Brass Band.
[ Up‐tempo music plays ]
[ Laughs ]
Wow.
[ Music stops ]
Greiner: Wow.
Wow.
[ Applause ]
Tight. Really tight.
So, who wants
to rock 'n' roll?
Cuban:
Yeah, big difference.
You can really hear it
so clearly ‐‐ Wait.
so clearly.
Greiner:
You know what?
Mann: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, there was
a huge difference.
Is it 50% reduction?
No, so, it's gonna reduce
22 decibels on average
across frequencies.
What decibel level
does this play at?
I'd say
95 to 105 decibels.
So, to give you
a point of reference,
95 in an arena is loud.
So, anything above 85 decibels
is damaging to your hearing.
So at 100 to 115 decibels,
you're damaging your ears
within 15 minutes.
How loud is
the average dance club?
Around 100 decibels.
That's a good question.
So you're doing damage,
for sure.
The average concert
is 100 to 110 decibels.
O'Leary: So...
So absolutely,
you're doing damage.
I was curious
to see these guys,
who are amazing,
aren't wearing these things.
Ta‐da!
Greiner: Ohh!
Corcoran: Ohh!
They are! Look.
That speaks to
how damn invisible they are.
Mann: Yes, yes.
Amazing.
Actually, McNasty, thank you
very much for your time.
Sacca: You guys are great.
And I got it from here.
[ Corcoran chuckles ]
[ Up‐tempo music plays ]
Okay, let's get into
the numbers.
My line of cost is $4.
Okay.
They retail
for $23.99.
Seems like a lot to me.
Yeah.
Yeah, it does
seem like a lot.
Sacca: So, all right,
I'm pulling this thing apart.
I take off the earpiece, and
I've got this conical interface.
There's some metal in there.
What is that?
Mann: That is the acoustic
filter which we use,
and that helps balance
the sound frequencies.
Is that something
you created?
No, that is often used
in hearing aids, actually,
to help speech intelligibility
and ‐‐ and sound to travel.
Jackson, you know,
my son writes music ‐‐
electronic dance music.
He's an engineer, as well.
And I have
some massive Cletron speakers.
He likes to crank them...
Oh.
... to crazy levels.
And so over time,
he's gone online
and bought everybody
in the family your competitor,
which we have by the dozens
lying all over the house.
They're not $23.
They're significantly cheaper.
They do exactly the same thing.
Correct.
I carry a pair of these
everywhere I go.
Mann: Yep.
Because I'm a very hip guy.
[ Chuckles ]
Fundamentally,
those are meant to be seen,
and I don't think
the market's ready for that.
There's too much stigma.
Oh, so that's the difference?
You're not gonna see this,
and these are?
Interesting point.
That could change my mind.
There'd be
certain situations
where I don't want
to be seen wearing earplugs.
People aren't ready to ‐‐
to be seen wearing these,
and making them
a fashion statement is ‐‐
What stops these guys
from just doing the same thing?
We are patent‐pending
in the U. S.
Sacca: For what?
For utility and design.
Yeah, but for what?
It has to do with the actual
dimensions that are in it,
how the sound moves
within it,
and then where certain filters
are placed.
Corcoran: Jackson,
where are you selling them now,
and what are your sales?
We're selling them online
through our own website,
as well as on‐site
at certain events
and through some wholesale
and retail.
We've been selling
for the last five months,
and our sales are $30,000.
Ooh.
Greiner: Do you think
that your sales are low
because there are
so many competitors,
or you just haven't been able
to get it out there enough yet?
I don't think we've been able to
get it out there as we need to.
We just got going
with a national distributor.
They've started to sell
to music stores.
We're in about 20
right now.
So it's ‐‐
Sacca: The biggest challenge
in this market is the fact
that they're never with you
when you need them.
The point of purchase
is so far away
in both space and time
from the point at which
you need to use them.
We've all been at the concert
that's too damn loud,
and you're like,
"God, I got to find a tissue
or something
to stuff in my ears."
[ Chuckles ]
Sure.
The big challenge here
is, what are you gonna do
to get these things
closest to the people who need
them at the time they need them?
That has been the disconnect
that I see, and, really,
the music entities themselves
need to come on board to this.
They don't care.
And as I mentioned ‐‐
No, we do care.
I think they do care.
Look, I own an arena,
and we book music.
Yep.
And, you know, when
the Mavs play, it can get loud.
And you see coaches
that have earplugs.
And these would be great.
But they have to be giveaways.
And at $4 cost, you can't afford
to price them as giveaways.
And I don't think you can
make it a big enough market
to make it worthwhile.
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Sacca: I'm gonna jump in, too.
I mean,
as my grandmother taught me,
never be bashful
about ending the meeting early.
I don't want to waste your time
or my time.
This is interesting enough.
I might be a user of them,
but, like I said,
the biggest holy grail here
is I need them
at the moment I need them,
and they're never at the moment
I can purchase them.
I don't know
how you fix that problem.
And so I'm sorry ‐‐ I'm pulling
the plug on this one. I'm out.
Jackson,
I fear you can't sell.
And if you can't sell
this product into whatever store
that you wanted to go into,
who's gonna do the selling?
You need to be a salesman,
and for that reason, I'm out.
You know,
it's a quality product.
But this is something
that I think people look at
for the time
in which they need it.
But it's not something
that they need all the time.
So I think
it's a very hard sell.
I'm out.
Here's my take
of the situation.
I'm the only guy here that
actually has a pair of these ‐‐
not yours, obviously ‐‐
in my pocket.
I like your product for the
very fact that you can't see it.
Here's the problem
with your deal.
There's not that much
proprietary element
to your product.
I think Chris tore it apart
and looked at it.
Anyways, I'm only gonna
make you one offer,
and I'm not gonna negotiate.
Here's the deal ‐‐
This is a classic royalty deal.
I'll give you the $100,000
with a royalty of $2
for every pair sold
until I get my money back.
And I want 35% of the company
to be an ongoing partner.
So I'm not asking for anything
more than my money back
in a way
that I have a true path.
Then I'll join you
in a partnership.
I'll promote this thing,
using your product every day.
And I would use it every day.
It's my only offer.
Not interested in negotiating.
Take it or leave it.
♪♪
I'm not interested
in a royalty deal at this time.
♪♪
I can't hear you.
No counter?
I said the only deal
I wanted to make.
Okay.
Sacca: Look, when you come up
with a version
that filters out Kevin,
come back.
The rest of us will buy it
from you.
Deal. Deal.
[ Greiner chuckles ]
Congratulations,
Jackson.
Greiner: Good luck.
Good luck
with your company.
O'Leary: Thank you.
Take care.
Thank you.
I know that Kevin often goes
to royalty deals.
I already knew going in there
that that wasn't something
I was willing to take.
The business is too small,
and we can't be pulling money
out of it at this time.
♪♪
Narrator: Next in the Tank
is a modern version
of a favorite childhood toy.
♪♪
Hi.
I'm Amelia Cosgrove.
And I'm Bryan Thomas.
And we're the co‐founders
of Pop Up Play,
from Austin, Texas.
We're seeking $250,000
in exchange
for 6% of our company.
♪♪
Now, Sharks, some of
our most memorable experiences
when we were kids
was when we played with toys
that we created ourselves,
like playing make‐believe
or building forts.
Well, kids play differently
today.
They're spending a lot more
time on screens consuming,
instead of creating.
At Pop Up Play,
we blend modern technology
with timeless play
to create a new, engaging
experience for kids.
It all starts on their tablet,
in the Pop Up Play Build Lab.
First, they choose
from options,
like a rocket ship, castle,
or gingerbread house.
They choose where to place
structural components,
like towers and doors,
then decorate
with large‐scale graphics.
Then, at the press of a button,
their design comes to life
and arrives at their doorstep
just a few days later.
Ding‐dong!
Cuban: Hey!
Aw!
Cosgrove:
They can play make‐believe
or color in
this life‐size coloring book
they designed themselves.
Now, parents ‐‐
and, obviously, kids ‐‐
They love Pop Up Play.
But the opportunity
is much bigger than that.
We've had significant
inbound interest
from some of the world's
largest brands,
who want our help
solving their problem
of engaging with kids
and their families.
In fact, we already
have a partnership
with one of the world's
largest automakers,
and we have a pipeline
with over 75 companies.
So come on, Sharks,
and join the fun.
It's time to imagine,
create...
Both: ... and play!
Thanks for coming,
guys.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you!
Greiner: Bye, guys.
Corcoran: Bye, guys.
Cosgrove: All right.
♪♪
Sacca: What are you best at?
Which part of this
is your core competency?
Yeah, so, we are ‐‐ we are
a software company, Chris.
So we see ourselves
as a platform to enable
custom, on‐demand design
and manufacturing of products.
By the way, did you say
what your relationship was?
We didn't.
We're married.
Oh. Do you have children?
Congrats.
We don't have kids yet.
Pop Up Play is our baby.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's good.
I know how that goes.
Walk us through
an average order.
Let's get to some numbers.
Sure.
Forget about the ‐‐
the big high end
and the low end.
Just the middle of the road.
Each order, no matter what
a child designs,
is a flat $99 price point.
Okay.
And then we charge
a flat $10 shipping
for the delivery
of each item.
How many have you sold
to date?
In about
the last 11 months,
we've done about $330,000
in revenue.
Sacca: Wow.
Corcoran: Wow.
And that's ‐‐ that is
composed of two components.
We just booked a deal
with one of the world's
largest automakers
that's valued
at $300,000.
Ohh!
So, wait. That's all
of your revenue, practically.
You're saying you're $330,000
in ‐‐ in the ‐‐ in the year.
And you're anticipating $300,000
comes from them?
Yes.
So you've only sold $30,000
outside of them?
That's right. Yeah.
That's not good news.
That's not good news at all.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but they have discovered
that most of Pop Up Play's
$330,000 revenue
has come from a single source.
We just booked a deal
with one of the world's
largest automakers
that's valued at $300,000.
Ohh!
That's all of your revenue,
practically.
So you've only sold $30,000
outside of them?
That's right, yeah.
That's not good news.
That's not good news at all.
My concern about it is,
we don't know the model
in terms of customer acquisition
and scale.
How many downloads
have you had of your app?
So, about 2,100 downloads.
Have you spent any money
on advertising
to drive those 2,100?
Around $15,000.
Okay, so to get 2,100 downloads.
That's right.
And did they lead directly to ‐‐
to the $30,000 in sales?
Yes.
So, we also had a Kickstarter
campaign last May.
There you go.
Ahh!
Oh.
That's the missing piece.
Okay, so how much of that
was Kickstarter?
You don't have any ‐‐
Cuban:
Wait, wait, Kevin, hold on.
How much of that
was Kickstarter?
$15,000.
So you spent $15,000
to get $15,000 in sales,
which is why you had to pivot
to the brand.
Thomas:
That's right.
Okay.
This was obvious to us
that it was a much more
lucrative opportunity
in terms of dealing with brands.
Remember, we had an ‐‐
But a much longer
sales process,
much more expensive to convert
sales process.
Okay, so, I have two deals
in the same space ‐‐
Paper Box Pilots
and Surprise Ride.
Mm‐hmm.
It's always the same story ‐‐
customer acquisition costs.
Yeah, so, we're not
in the toy business, Kevin.
And I just want to make sure
we're on the same page here.
We're an on‐demand design
and manufacturing company.
Got it.
We are working with brands
as a go‐to‐market strategy.
And so we originally worked
with consumers directly.
You don't care
about acquiring consumers.
That's correct.
Not anymore, yeah.
You basically want
to go find more.
That's a different
sales process.
Absolutely.
Cosgrove:
Yes, absolutely.
That's why they changed.
That's why they pivoted.
Yeah, but I'm not sure
it's more lucrative,
because
it's a long sales cycle.
That's what I said, Kevin.
Where have you been?
[ Chuckles ]
To ‐‐ To me, it's ‐‐
I go right back to looking at it
saying, "I've got, I don't know,
a quarter of a million customers
that have already bought
in that age bracket."
Uh‐huh.
But it's not clear to me
that you know
what the customer acquisition
cost is
before I give you
that database.
So I'm not your Shark.
I'm out.
Okay, Kevin.
Thank you for your time.
Cosgrove:
Thanks. Thanks.
There's got to be
a lot of people
making this type of product.
I feel like
I've seen it before.
Cosgrove: Right, well,
there are products like this.
Right.
Not the experience.
And what's the range
of what they sell for?
So, they sell
from about $35 to $90.
I think
the price is too high.
And you haven't
proven anything.
You have one client that's been
the bulk of your sales.
I don't really believe
it's a business yet.
Okay.
So, with all due respect,
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you
for your time.
So, how much money
did you raise?
So, we've raised
$325,000
from Techstars,
Capital Factory,
Silverton Partners,
and Floodgate.
Okay.
And what valuation
did you do then?
And what was the valuation
of that round?
That was
a $3 million valuation.
I think that
it's a very clever idea.
On the flip side,
for me right now,
as an investment,
it's a little too early.
I'm not sure
what direction we'd be going.
Thomas: Okay.
Cosgrove: Okay.
And so I'm out.
Well, thank you
for your time, Lori.
Thanks.
You didn't design
this software
with the vision
of building kids castles.
The initial concept was toys,
but we knew really early on
that it could apply
to things far beyond toys.
What else can you make
with this software here?
This can be used
to cut any sheet material.
So we're talking sheet metal.
We're talking wood, fabric.
Can you guys integrate to ‐‐
into Minecraft as a mod at all?
[ Chuckles ]
I know.
We would love to,
easily.
Wouldn't that be great?
Cosgrove: Yeah.
Sacca: So, just to be clear,
you think in the future,
a kid could export
their Minecraft design
through your software all the
way through to be manufactured?
But the problem is getting
Microsoft to go along.
So, technically speaking, Chris,
we could do that right now,
today, if the partnership
was in place.
Okay, well, I don't agree
with the one‐off brand sales,
because that makes you
more of a sales organization,
and it goes away
from your core competency.
It doesn't add up
to an investment for me.
I'm out.
Sure. So I'm ‐‐
O'Leary: Still one Shark left.
No point
in talking to him anymore.
♪♪
Sacca:
Let ‐‐ Let's talk.
Right off the bat, it's fun,
and I think that's something
that sometimes all these
soulless capitalists up here
forget to recognize.
That said, 21,000 downloads
or 150 purchases ‐‐
I mean, you're off like
a herd of turtles so far, right?
[ Chuckles ]
So I don't quite see
the acceleration yet.
And so there's a lot of risk,
as a result.
I see the valuation
you're looking for,
and it's a premium on where
the last investors came in.
So I'm gonna make you an offer.
♪♪
I'll come into your deal
for the $250,000,
but at the same terms as your
prior investors invested in.
Yes.
What were those terms?
$3 million cap,
8% interest,
36‐month maturity
on the note.
Okay, that's my offer.
I'm in for 250k on those terms.
Okay.
Can you give us
a moment to speak?
Sure.
I mean, you're husband and wife.
You can probably just ‐‐
It's like telepathy
at this point, but...
[ Chuckles ]
[ Indistinct whispering ]
♪♪
Yeah.
Yeah, we'll ‐‐
we'll do it.
We'd love
to have you.
Right on. All right.
Cuban: Congratulations, guys.
Good job.
Thank you.
Congratulations, guys.
Thank you very much.
This is awesome.
Awesome.
All right.
Thank you.
Congrats, guys.
Thomas: This is fun.
Thank you.
Good job.
Thomas: Chris has
a ton of credibility.
I mean,
he picks winners.
And for him to put his name
on Pop Up Play is ‐‐
is a significant honor,
and we're really excited
about it.
♪♪
I'm John Staff.
And I'm Pete Davis.
And we're here in the beautiful
Catskills in Upstate New York.
And we are the creators
of Getaway.
John and I met at college,
where we had both moved
from a small town
to the big city
with all the hustle
and bustle.
As society
gets more technological,
people are desperate
for an escape hatch,
and it turns out
that escape hatch
is all around us ‐‐
the great outdoors.
[ Birds chirping ]
With Getaway, you go
to a beautiful tiny house
in the woods, where you can
just disconnect and recharge.
A tiny house is exactly
what it sounds like.
It's a regular house
with windows and doors
and a cooktop and a bathroom
and a shower, but shrunken.
You sit
by the campfire.
You roast marshmallows.
You read a good book.
You just do nothing.
Hello. This is John
with Getaway.
We're going on "Shark Tank"
because we want to level up
from a cool idea
to a national phenomenon.
But we also think it's important
to impact people's lives
by providing them a way
to recharge and find balance.
And we want to provide that
to as many people as we can.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is John Staff.
And I'm Pete Davis.
We're from Boston,
Massachusetts,
and our company
is Getaway.
We're asking for $500,000
for 5% of our company,
which is providing
hardworking Americans
a new way to disconnect
and recharge.
You need a getaway.
You need to find a way
to carve out time to unplug.
That's where we come in.
Getaway has handcrafted
the perfect way to escape.
Here's how it works.
You're having a super‐stressful
day at work,
and you think,
"I need to get away."
"I need a getaway."
[ Laughs ]
You go to our website,
you pick out your favorite
tiny house design, and boom.
Boom.
You're texted a key code
and a map
to your own Getaway house
in the woods.
You hop in your car. You pick up
your friends or family.
You hightail it
out of the city.
And in an hour or two,
your own personal,
beautiful tiny house,
surrounded by serene woods,
is waiting for you.
With your cellphone
locked away
and marshmallows roasting
in the fire pit
waiting to become s'mores,
work, for that moment,
becomes a distant memory.
Okay, Sharks,
with your help,
we can make the instant cabin
available nationwide.
Let's talk about the model,
because that, I assume,
is rolled into place,
it's the land you lease.
Correct.
Close to Boston.
Let's take the Boston market.
So, we put
these things up
to two hours
outside of the city.
It's designed
to be an affordable,
quick getaway
from the city,
where you just
totally disconnect.
We design
these tiny houses.
We put them
on beautiful rural land,
and then
folks come out to them.
So they pay $99 per night,
and they're completely set up
and ready to go because the idea
is that it has to be simple.
Will I find Kevin
at the next house
on the other side
of the treeline?
[ Chuckles ]
We design the spot
so that it feels like
it's your own private
tiny house in the woods.
Because people
say, like,
"I just don't want
to see any humans.
I'm sick of my house."
So no one else is around.
Although, on the flip side,
that could be, like,
out of a horror movie.
[ Screeches ]
[ Laughs ] Good point.
What about security?
So, you're all alone.
You're out in the woods.
Very remote.
Feels like a great setup
for, like, a "Blair Witch."
Yeah, it does.
So, we have a site manager
that's very close by,
and they don't know
the site manager's there,
but if something
goes wrong,
there's someone right there
very fast.
It's much safer
than camping.
Right, so the economics
have got to be great, right,
'cause your cost of land
is next to nothing.
It costs you how much
to build a house?
$30,000 to build a house.
It's a quarter ‐‐
One‐quarter
of what a hotel costs.
So the houses pay themselves
back in 18 months, currently,
and that's coming down.
We get the same daily rate
as a hotel night
and double the margin.
The issue is
utilization rate, right,
because you're not gonna
rent these every day,
and depending on where they are
in the country,
you have snow issues,
other issues, right?
Yeah, let me ‐‐
Mark, great news.
We're at close to 100% occupancy
with all of our cabins.
How many cabins do you have?
10 cabins.
Well, that's why. Right?
Yeah.
What are you gonna do
with the money?
We want to bring Getaway
national.
We want to really be the
instant cabin nationwide brand,
and we're only in New York
and Boston now,
but if you give us the money,
we can expand to the West Coast.
Have you guys
already raised money?
Yeah, we've raised $1.2 million
in seed capital.
Oh!
What valuation?
Sacca: At what valuation?
Most recently,
at a $7 million valuation.
Whoa.
Let me talk about
how we got to
the valuation we're at.
So, number one, we've
raised money previously.
Number two, we're actively
fundraising right now.
All of those meetings
we're having
with VCs
across the country
are about a $12‐ to $15 million
pre‐money valuation,
and nobody's
blinking an eye.
We're coming here
with a $10 million valuation
because we know you guys
are worth the discount,
because of all the value
you're gonna bring.
We're so flattered.
Thank you so much,
being worth the discount.
We mean it.
Especially you, Barbara.
Oh, how lovely.
Walk us through
your revenue assumptions.
What are you gonna make
this calendar year?
What is free cash flow?
We're gonna do
almost $300,000 this year.
We get a 60% margin
on that.
Next year, we're gonna do
$2.1 million.
Where do you expect
to be in five years?
Five years,
we're gonna be in 30 cities
with 30 units
in the U. S.
That's 1,000 units.
Okay, so 1,000 units
at $30,000 a unit.
So that's $30 million
right there.
Yeah.
What is it gonna cost you
to manage a city?
Because over time, particularly
because of the elements,
you're gonna have to depreciate
those assets.
So, we depreciate these things
over 10 years with ‐‐
Too long. Too long.
I think after seven years
in a New England winter,
that thing's gonna look like
a piece of crap.
Sacca: If not sooner.
So I think
the problem with this deal
you're gonna find out with other
Sharks ‐‐ I may be wrong ‐‐
is that there's gonna be
a big fight about valuation
because nobody wants to put it
in at a $10 million valuation.
So they're gonna ask
for a lot more equity.
I'm going the other way.
Here's the deal.
I'll give you a loan
of $500,000
for three years at 11%.
And for all the trouble I'm
gonna go through to set that up,
I want 2.5% of the equity
of the company right now.
Here's what
really concerns me.
You have 10 tiny cabins ‐‐
You're out here
peddling for $10 million.
So I don't understand
how you got there,
but I sure know
the bottom line makes no sense,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you, Barbara.
Thank you.
Cuban: Look, guys,
the problem is scale.
In order for you
to get to be a big company,
it's gonna be tough, right?
You're gonna be raising money
from now until evermore,
because you have to keep on
building houses
and you have to keep on
rebuilding any houses
if the elements take their toll
more than you expect.
You're gonna be raising money
for a long time.
You're gonna get diluted
further,
and I'm gonna have to keep on
investing more and more money
just to keep my equity.
Heavy capital investment,
not enough upside.
I'm out.
♪♪
Greiner:
I actually want to go,
when I go on vacation,
somewhere warm.
I want to be
by a gorgeous beach.
Being in the woods
creeps me out.
Like, it's not for me.
I see it's for
a lot of other people,
but I find it very scary.
I'm out.
Thanks, Lori.
You guys realize
you have an offer from Kevin?
[ Chuckles ]
We do.
O'Leary:
The risk you have now is,
if Sacca goes out,
I'm your only offer,
and you know
the kind of Shark I am.
Here's one thing
I'd like to say to Chris.
You have brought and shepherded
much technology into this world,
and you know technology
needs a counterbalance.
We can provide
that counterbalance.
You can pay amends for helping
bring Twitter into this world,
and this is
the anti‐Twitter.
What I'd invite you guys to do
is talk to me about valuation.
How fixed are you on
this implied $10 million price?
Now, let's see him talk you down
to a $3 million valuation.
No, I'm actually
asking you guys.
I'm politely deferring to you
to make me a fresh offer.
Thanks, Chris.
Can I ‐‐
This will boil down
to how much equity dilution
you want to take a hit on
and how much time
you want to spend on a phone
with your existing investors
explaining why
he should get a discount
and they shouldn't.
Last week and next week,
I'm meeting with VCs
across the country,
and I'm having
real conversations
about $12‐ to $15 million
valuations.
And you're gonna have
to tell them that Chris Sacca
is special and worth a lot more
than they are.
And that's
why we came in ‐‐
If you're say you're meeting
with real VCs,
what does that mean I am?
Cuban: Yeah,
and what does that say
to the people
who have already invested?
Look, if you've got
a bird in the hand
at a $15 million valuation,
what are you doing here?
You guys are great investors,
and you can add a lot of value.
If you're worried
5% is too small,
we're not gonna pay attention
to you,
we could go up to
$1 million for 10%.
What a deal.
What's the difference?
That's the same valuation.
Same valuation.
I asked you guys to make me
an offer on valuation,
and you came back
with the same damn price,
asking me to put
twice as much money in.
[ Chuckles ]
Kevin's offer is better.
You're gonna be diluted
to nothing.
You're gonna have
that never‐ending battle
to try
to retain your equity.
Chris,
what do you want to do?
Your reaction to Kevin's offer
tells me a lot
about the deal
you want to do with me.
Uh‐huh.
Your unwillingness to do
the debt deal makes me think
you don't actually believe
that much in the value
of your own equity.
That's not true.
And that scares me.
So true. You're right.
We haven't reacted
to Kevin's offer.
You haven't reacted
to Kevin's offer?
You've been standing there doing
nothing with Kevin's offer.
Kevin's offer includes
we give up 2.5%
of our business.
O'Leary: Right.
I don't know why you're not
taking that deal,
and it scares me about the deal
I'm thinking about doing.
O'Leary:
Guys, I'm gonna bring this
to a head, okay?
I'm gonna give you 10 seconds
to take my offer or not,
'cause I'm actually
getting bored.
♪♪
Narrator: Three sharks are out.
Pete and John have an offer
on the table from Kevin
for their tiny cabin
rental business, Getaway.
But they also want to see
if Chris is interested.
Guys, I'm gonna give you
10 seconds to take my offer
or not, 'cause I'm actually
getting bored.
You can decide yes or no.
In 10 seconds, I'm out,
and then you can hope
you can cut a deal with him.
Chris,
do you have an offer?
Uh, I‐I would ‐‐
Five...
I would come back in at the same
terms as your other investors ‐‐
at 500k at the same terms
of your prior investors.
I'm out.
That offer's gone.
500k at
a $7 million valuation.
Yeah, I would ‐‐ Well, actually,
let's talk now,
because the clock just expired
with O'Leary,
and now it's just you and me
and your tiny houses.
Chris, you realize
that this is ‐‐
This cannot be
a one‐time investment.
This is
a capital‐intensive business
that's gonna require
a lot more,
and this negotiation over equity
has to take place every time
because
they're gonna be diluted.
I get it.
But ultimately, when something's
worth $1 billion,
if I only own 3% of it,
we still make a ton of money.
Sounds like
a "yes" is on its way.
What are you gonna do,
Chris?
♪♪
Well, now there's no competitive
bids in the market.
Anything else you can do
to sweeten the deal?
♪♪
If you want
to do $500,000
at a $7 million valuation
straight equity,
we'd do that deal.
♪♪
Now, that's got to be
after that prior note converts
so that I end up with 7%‐plus
of the company.
Do we agree?
♪♪
After it converts?
So the other note
converts before me,
and then I get brought in
at a $7 million valuation.
And your ‐‐ your other investors
are gonna be okay with that?
No chance in hell
would they agree to that.
Sacca: So I get 7%‐plus
of the company.
That's after all your other
investors have converted.
Let's talk
for a minute.
Yeah, we're gonna talk
Just here.
That will never happen.
If they do, I...
Yeah.
♪♪
I don't think
we can do that.
Greiner: Wow.
It's too hard
when we're out raising money
at a much higher
valuation.
I understand. I get it.
I'm out.
Thanks for coming in,
guys.
Nice seeing you, guys.
Thank you.
Cuban:
Good luck, guys.
Staff:
Appreciate it.
Greiner: Good luck.
Corcoran: They seemed like
they were going to do it,
though, for a while there.
No, there's no way
they could do it.
You're getting anti‐dilution,
basically,
and no one else has it.
Sacca: You know
what happens sometimes?
You come in here
and you're negotiating
with a professional negotiator,
and before you know it,
you've just dug yourself into
a hole you can't get out of.
Staff:
We got to be loyal to the people
who brought us here,
and making that deal with Chris
would have been disloyal.
Look, when we're
a $1 billion company
and they're stressed out
that they're missing on
the returns they could have had,
we're gonna let them stay
in a Getaway.
We're the bigger men.
[ Laughs ]